i think the idea i would have is uh
to be a bit more rigorous in
trying to measure the amount of
love you add or subtract from the world
in second third
fourth fifth order effects it's
actually i think especially in the world
of tech quite doable
you know you just might not like
you know the the shareholders may not
like that kind of metric
but it's pretty easy to measure like
that's not even
i'm perhaps half joking about love but
we could talk about just happiness and
well-being long-term well-being
it's pretty easy for facebook for
youtube for all these
companies to measure that they do a lot
of kinds of surveys
they could do i mean there's very simple
solutions here that you could just
survey how i mean servers are
in some sense use useless because
they're um
a subset of the population you're just
trying to get a sense it's very loose
kind of understanding
but integrated deeply as part of the
technology most of our tech is
recommender systems
most of the sorry not tech online
interaction is driven by recommender
systems that
learn very little data about you and use
that data
based on mostly based on traces your
previous behavior to suggest
future things this is how twitter is how
facebook works this is how
uh adsense for google adsense works is
how netflix youtube work and so on
and and for them to just track as
opposed to engagement
how much you spend in a particular video
a particular site
is also track give you the technology to
do
self-report of what makes you feel good
what makes you grow as a person
of what makes you uh
you know the best version of yourself
the the the the rogan uh idea of the
hero of your movie
and just add that little bit of
information
if you you have people you have this
like happiness surveys of
how you feel about the last five days
how would you report
your experience you can lay out a set of
videos it's kind of fascinating
i don't know if you ever look at youtube
the history of videos you've looked at
it's fascinating it's very embarrassing
for me like
it'll be like a lecture and then like a
set of videos that i don't want anyone
to know about
which is which which will be like i
don't know
maybe like five videos in a row where it
looks like i watched the whole thing
which i probably did about like how to
cook a steak even though
or just like the best chefs in the world
cooking steaks and i'm just like
sitting there watching it for no purpose
whatsoever wasting away my life
or like funny cat videos or like legit
that's that's that's always a good one
and i could look back
and rate which videos made me a better
person and not
and i mean on a more serious note
there's a bunch of conversations
podcasts or
lectures i've watched which made me a
better person and some that made me a
worse person
uh quite honestly not for stupid reasons
like i feel dumber
but because i do have a sense that that
started me
on a path of um
of not being kind to other people for
example i'll give you
uh for my own and i'm sorry for ranting
but maybe there's some usefulness to
this kind of exploration of self
when i focus on creating i'm programming
on science
i become a much deeper thinker
and a kinder person to others when i
listen to too many
a little bit as good but too many
podcasts or videos about how
how our world is melting down or
criticizing ridiculous people the worst
of the quote unquote woke for example
all
there's all these groups that are
misbehaving
in fascinating ways because they've been
corrupted by power
the more i want the more i watch
criticism
of them the worse i become
and i'm aware of this but i'm also aware
that
for some reason it's pleasant to watch
those sometimes
and so for for me to be able to
self-report that to the youtube
algorithm
to the systems around me and they
ultimately try to optimize
to make me the best person the best
version of myself
which i personally believe would make
youtube a lot more money because i'd be
much more willing to spend time on
youtube and give youtube a lot more
a lot more of my money that's a that's
great for business
and great for humanity because it'll
make me a kinder person
it'll increase the the love quotient
the love metric and uh it'll make them a
lot of money i feel like everything is
aligned
and so you you should do that not just
for youtube algorithm but also for
military strategy and whether you go to
war or not because
one externality you can think of about
going to war
which i think we talked about offline is
we often go to
war with kind of governments with a uh
with
not with the people you have to think
about
the kids of countries
that see a soldier and
because of what they experience their
interaction with the soldier
hate is born when you're like eight
years old
six years old you lose your dad you lose
your mom
you lose a friend somebody close to you
that one a
really powerful externality that could
be reduced to love
positive and negative is uh
the hate that's born when you make
decisions and that's going to
take fruition that that little seed is
going to become a tree that then leads
to the kind of destruction
that we talk about
uh so but my sense it's possible to
reduce everything to a measure of how
much love does this add to the world
all that to say uh do you have ideas of
how we practically
uh build systems
that that create a resilient society
there are a lot of good things that you
shared where there's like
15 different ways that we could enter
this that are all interesting so i'm
trying to see which one will probably be
most useful pick the uh
the one or two things that are least
ridiculous and you're mentioning
if we could see some of the
second order effects or externalities
that we aren't used to seeing
specifically the one
of a kid being radicalized somewhere
else which engenders enmity in them
towards us which decreases our own
future security
even if you don't care about the kid if
you care about the kids the whole other
thing
um yeah i mean i think when
we saw this when jane fonda and others
went to vietnam and took
photos and videos of what was happening
and you got to see the pictures of
the kids with napalm on them uh
that like the anti-war effort was
bolstered by that in a way it couldn't
have been without that there's there's a
until we can see the images you can't
have a mirror neuron
effect in the same way and when you can
that starts to have a
powerful effect i think there's a deep
principle that you're
sharing there which is
that if we we can have a rivalrous
intent
where our in-group whatever it is maybe
it's our political party wanting to win
within the u.s maybe it's our
nation state wanting to win in a a war
or
an economic war over resource or
whatever it is
that if we don't obliterate the other
people completely
they don't go away they're they're not
engendered to like us more
they didn't become less smart so they
have more enmity towards us and whatever
technologies we employed to be
successful they will now reverse
engineer
make iterations on and come back and so
you drive in arms race which is why you
can see
that the wars were over
history employing more lethal weaponry
and not just the kinetic war um
the information war and the narrative
war and the
economic war right like it just
increased capacity in all of those
fronts
um and so what seems like a win to us
on the short term might actually really
produce losses in the long term
and what's even in our own best interest
in the long term is probably more
aligned with everyone else because we
inter-affect each other
and i think the thing about globalism
globalization
and exponential tech and the rate at
which we affect each other and the rate
at which we affect the biosphere that
we're all affected by
is that this this kind of
proverbial spiritual idea that we're all
interconnected and need to think about
that in some way
it was easy for tribes to get because
everyone in the tribe
so clearly saw their inner connection
and dependence on each other
but in terms of a global level the
the speed at which we are actually
interconnected the speed at which the
harm happening to something in
wuhan affects the rest of the world or a
new technology developed somewhere
affects the entire world or an
environmental issue or whatever
is making it to where we either actually
all get
not as a spiritual idea just even as
physics right we all get
the interconnectedness of everything and
that we either all consider that and see
how to make it through more effectively
together
or failures anywhere end up becoming
decreased quality of life and failures
and increased risk everywhere
don't you think people are beginning to
experience that at the individual level
so governments are resisting it
they're they're trying to make us not
empathize with each other feel connected
but don't you think people are beginning
to feel more and more connected
like isn't that exactly what the
technology is enabling like social
networks we tend to criticize them but
isn't there a sense which were
experience you know when you watch those
videos that are criticizing whether it's
the woke antifa side or the q anon trump
supporter
side does it seem like they
have increased empathy for people that
are outside of their ideological not at
all
so i may be
i may be conflating my own experience of
the world
and that of
that of the populace i i tend to see
those videos
as feeding something that's a relic of
the past
they figured out that drama fuels clicks
but whether i'm right or wrong i don't
know but
i tend to sense that that is not
that hunger for drama is not fundamental
to human beings
that we want to actually
that we want to understand antifa and we
want to
like empathize we want to take radical
ideas
and be able to empathize with them and
synthesize it all
okay let's look at
cultural outliers in terms of
violence versus compassion we can see
that a lot of cultures have
relatively lower in-group violence
bigger out-group violence and there's
some variants in them and variants at
different times based on the scarcity or
abundance of resource and other things
but you can look at say
whose whole religion is around
non-violence so much so that they don't
even hurt plants they
only take fruits that fall off them and
stuff or
to go to a larger population you could
take buddhists where for the most part
with a few exceptions for the most part
across three millennia
and across lots of different countries
and geographies and whatever
you have 10 million people plus or minus
who don't hurt bugs
the whole spectrum of genetic variants
that is happening within a culture of
that many people
and head traumas whatever and nobody
hurts bugs
and then you look at a group where the
kids grow up as child soldiers in
liberia or darfur
where to make it to adulthood pretty
much everybody's killed people
hand-to-hand
and killed people who were civilian or
innocent type people
and you say okay so we were very neonos
we can be conditioned by our environment
and humans can
be conditioned where almost all the
humans show up in these two different
bell curves it doesn't mean that the
buddhists had no violence it doesn't
mean that these people had no compassion
but the
they're very different gaussian
distributions
and so i think one of the important
things
that i like to do is look at the
examples of the
populations what buddhism shows
regarding compassion or what
judaism shows around education the
average level of education that
everybody gets because of a culture that
is really working on conditioning
it or various cultures what are the
positive deviants
outside of this statistical deviance to
see
what is actually possible and then say
what are the
conditioning factors and can we
condition those across a few of them
simultaneously
and could we build a civilization like
that becomes a very
interesting question so there's this
kind of real politic idea that
humans are violent large groups of
humans become
violent they become irrational
specifically those two things rivalrous
and violent and irrational
and so in order to minimize the total
amount of violence and have some good
decisions they need ruled somehow
and that not getting that is some kind
of naive utopianism that doesn't
understand
human nature yet this gets back to like
mimesis of desire as an inexorable thing
i think the idea of the masses is
actually a kind of propaganda
that is useful for the classes that
control
um to popularize the idea that most
people are too violent lazy um
undisciplined and irrational to make
good choices
and therefore their choices should be
sublimated in some kind of way
i think that if we look back at these
conditioning environments
we can say okay so the kids
they go to
a really fancy school and have a good
developmental environment like exeter
academy
there's still a gaussian distribution of
how well they do on any particular
metric
but on average they become senators and
the worst ones become high-end lawyers
or whatever
and then i look at an inner city school
with a totally different set of things
and i see a very very differently
displaced gaussian distribution but very
different set of conditioning factors so
then i say the masses
well if all those kids who were one of
the parts of the masses got to go to
exeter and have that family and whatever
would they still be the masses
um could we actually condition
more social virtue more civic virtue
more orientation towards dialectical
synthesis
more empathy more rationality widely
yes would that lead to
better capacity for something like
participatory governance democracy or
republic or some kind of participatory
governance
yes yes is it necessary for it actually
yes and is it good for class interests
not not really by the way when you say
class
interest this is the powerful leading
over the less powerful that kind of idea
anyone that benefits from asymmetries of
power
doesn't necessarily benefit from
decreasing those asymmetries of power
and
kind of increasing the capacity of
people more widely and
um so when we talk about
power we're talking about asymmetries in
agency influence and control
you think that hunger for power is
fundamental to human nature
i think we should get that straight
before we talk about other stuff so like
uh
this uh this this pickup line that i use
at a bar off which is uh power corrupts
and absolute power crops absolutely
is that true or is that just a fancy
thing to say
in modern society there's something to
be said have we changed as societies
over time
in terms of how much we crave power
that there is an impulse towards power
that is innate in people and can be
conditioned
one way or the other yes but you can see
that buddhist society does a very
different thing with it at scale
that you don't end up seeing the
emergence of
the same types of sociopathic behavior
and particularly than creating
sociopathic institutions
um and so it's like
is eating the foods that were rare in
our evolutionary environment that give
us more dopamine hit because they were
rare and they're not anymore
salt fat sugar um is there something
pleasurable
about those where humans have an
orientation to overeat if they can well
the fact that there is that possibility
doesn't mean everyone will obligately be
obese and die of obesity right like
it's possible to have a uh
a particular impulse and to be able to
understand it have other ones and be
able to balance them
and so to say that um
power dynamics are are obligate in
humans and we can't do anything about it
is very similar to me
to saying like we could everyone is
going to be obligatedly obese
yeah so there's some degree to which
those the control those impulses
has to do with the conditioning early in
life yes and the culture
that creates the environment to be able
to do that and then the recursion on
that
okay so what if we were to uh just
bear with me just asking for a friend if
we were to kill all humans on earth
and then start over
is there ideas about how to build up
okay we don't have to kill let's leave
the humans on earth they're fine
and go to mars and start a new society
is there ways to construct systems of
conditioning
education of how we live with each other
that would um that would
incentivize us properly to not seek
power
not to not construct systems that are
of asymmetry of power and to create
systems that are resilient to all kinds
of terrorist attacks
to all kinds of destructions
i believe so so is there some inklings
we get
of course you probably don't have the
ant all the answers but you have
insights about what that looks like i
mean is it just rigorous practice of
dialectic
synthesis as essentially conversations
with [ __ ] of various flavors until
they're not [ __ ] anymore because
you've become
deeply apathetic with their experience
okay
so there's a lot of things that we
would need to construct to come back to
this like what is the basis of rivalry
what
how do you bind it how does it relate to
tech
if you have a culture that is doing less
rivalry does it always
lose in war to those who do war better
and how do you make something on the
enactment of how to get there from here
um great great so what's rivalry why is
rivalry bad or good
is is so is another word for our very
competition
yes i think roughly yes i think
bad and good are kind of silly concepts
here
good for some things bad for other
things for some contexts and others
even that um okay let me give you an
example that relates back to the
facebook measuring thing you were
mentioning a moment ago
first i think what you're saying is
actually aligned with the right
direction and
what i want to get to in a moment um but
it's not the devil is in the details
here
so i i enjoy praise it feeds my ego i
grow stronger
so i appreciate that i will make sure to
include one piece every 15 minutes as we
thank you
um so
it's easier to measure
there are problems with this argument
but there's also utility to it so let's
take it
for the utility it has first
it's harder to measure happiness than it
is to measure comfort
uh we can measure with technology that
the shocks in a car are making the car
bounce less that the bed is softer
and you know material science and those
types of things and happiness
is actually hard for philosophers to
define because
some people find that there are certain
kinds of overcoming suffering that are
necessary for happiness there's
happiness it feels more like contentment
and happiness it feels more like passion
that's
is passion the source of all suffering
or the source of all creativity like the
there's deep stuff and it's mostly first
person not measurable third person stuff
even if maybe it corresponds to
third person stuff to some degree but we
also see examples of
some of our favorite examples is people
who are in the worst environments who
end up finding happiness right where the
third person stuff looks to be less
conducive and there's some victor
frankel nelson mandela or whatever
um but it's pretty easy to measure
comfort it's pretty universal and
i think we can see that the industrial
revolution started to replace
happiness with comfort quite heavily as
the thing it was optimizing for and we
can see that when increased comfort is
given maybe because of the evolutionary
disposition
that expending extra calories when for
the majority of our history we didn't
have extra calories was not a
safe thing to do who knows why um
when extra comfort is given it's very
easy
to take that path even if it's not the
path that supports overall well-being
long-term
and um so we can see that
you know when you when you look at the
techno-optimist idea that we have better
lives than
egyptian pharaohs and kings and whatever
what they're largely looking at
is how comfortable our beds are
and how comfortable the transportation
systems are and things like that in
which case there's massive improvement
but we also see that in some of the
nations where people have access to the
most comfort suicide and mental illness
of the highest
and we also see that some of the
happiest cultures
are actually some of the ones that are
in materially lame environments
and so there's a very interesting
question here and if i
understand correctly you do cold showers
and
joe rogan's talking about how he needs
to do some fairly intensive kind of
struggle that is a non-comfort to
actually induce being better as a person
this concept of hormesis that
it's actually stressing an adaptive
system that increases its adaptive
capacity
and that there's something that the
happiness of a system has
something to do with its adaptive
capacity its overall resilience health
well-being which requires a decent bit
of
discomfort and yet
in the in the presence of the comfort
solution it's very hard to not choose it
and then
as you're choosing it regularly to
actually down regulate your overall
adaptive capacity
and so when we start saying can we
make tech where we're measuring for the
things that it produces beyond just
the measure of gdp or whatever
particular
measures look like the revenue
generation or profit generation of my
business
are all the meaningful things measurable
and what are the right measures and what
are the externalities of optimizing for
that measurement set what meaningful
things aren't included in that
measurement set that might have their
own externalities
these are some of the questions we
actually have to take seriously yeah and
we i think they're answerable questions
right progressively better not perfect
right so i so first of all let me throw
out happiness and comfort out of the
discussion those seems like useless
the distinction so i because i said
they're useful well-being is useful but
i think i take it back
i knew uh i proposed new metrics
in this brainstorm session which is uh
so one is like personal growth which is
intellectual growth i think we're able
to
make that concrete for ourselves like
you're a better person than you were
a week ago or a worse person than you
were a week ago i think we can
ourselves report that and and understand
what that means it's this gray area
and we try to define it but i think we
humans are pretty good at that
because we have a sense an idealistic
sense of the person we might be able to
become we we all dream of becoming a
certain kind of person and i think we
have a sense
of getting closer and not towards that
person
maybe this is not a great magic fine the
other one
is love actually [ __ ] if you're happy or
not
or you're comfortable or not how much
love do you have towards your fellow
human beings i feel like if you try to
optimize that
and increasing that that's going to have
that's a good metric
how many times a day sorry if i can make
quantify how many times a day have you
thought positively of another human
being
just put that down as a number and
increase that number
i think the process of saying okay
so let's not take gdp or gdp per capita
as the metric we want to optimize for
because gdp goes up during war and it
goes up with more health care spending
from sicker people and various things
that we wouldn't say correlate to
quality of life
uh addiction drives gdp awesomely um
by the way when i said growth i wasn't
referring to i know
i'm giving an example now of the primary
metric we use and why it's not not
equipment
because we're exploring other ones so
the idea of saying what would the
metrics
for a good civilization be if i had to
pick a set of metrics what would the
best ones be if i was going to optimize
for those
and then really try to run the thought
experiment
more deeply and say okay so what happens
if we optimize for that
try to think through the first and
second and third order effects of what
happens it's positive and then also say
what negative things can happen from
optimizing that what actually matters it
is not included
in that or in that way of defining it
because love versus
number of positive thoughts per day i
could just make a long list of names and
just think say positive thing about each
one it's all very superficial
not include animals or the rest of life
have a have a very
shallow total amount of it but i'm
optimizing the number and if i get some
credit for the number
so the and this is when i said the model
of reality isn't reality
when you make a set of metrics they were
going to optimize for this
whatever reality is that is not included
in those metrics can be the areas where
harm occurs which is why
i would say that wisdom is something
like
the discernment that leads to right
choices
beyond what metrics based optimization
would offer
you